[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host polius and paulias
and after the ending of loki episode 4 i
think we have a lot to talk about
in this video heads will roll as we go
through what's happening with the
timekeepers
who's behind them and what's with all
the loki variants in the post credits
scene
full spoilers ahead so if you don't
anything ruin then i recommend you say
bye bye frost and exit the video as fast
as possible
smash the thumbs up button if you enjoy
the breakdown and make sure you
subscribe as we're in the endgame of the
series now
and you definitely don't want to miss
our breakdowns without the way thank you
for clicking the video
now let's get into our loki episode 5
theories
okay so episode 4 ends with loki and
sylvie coming face to face with the
squidward
trio aka the timekeepers after throwing
her sword she beheaded the main one
and this exposed that they were actually
androids
life model decoys or other lmds are
something that have popped up in the
marvel universe at several points and
typically they're used for a reveal
just like this they often indicate that
someone has either duplicated themselves
in order to appear a certain way
or that someone else is behind it all
think i get that all along
and you get the picture now when they're
broken apart the robots look quite a lot
like doom bots
and though he could be behind it i
actually think that it's unlikely he
would be in the tva
instead i think there are some far more
likely candidates that are pulling the
strings
now the first potential is he who
remains in order to discuss him we have
to talk about how the universe works
and like all things it too comes to an
end
now when the universe dies it creates
something known as a heat death that
starts off the next universal
cycle and in the comics we discover that
he who remains was a tva member from the
previous one
he created the timekeepers and gave them
information so that on the next goal
they wouldn't make the same mistakes
and if we are keeping in with the comics
then he could be behind it all
now i think it's pretty unlikely that
it's him as he's always been
more of a force for good and the tva
themselves are quite sinister
thus it could actually be kang the
conqueror who has also been involved
with the organization
right after the release of endgame many
people thought that kang would be next
as when characters tend to mess with
time it tends to mess back
and he follows not long after jonathan
mages has been cast as the villain
and we do know that he's set to show up
in ant-man quantomania
however it would be pretty cool to see
him pop up at the end of the show
in a sort of thanos at the end of the
avengers moment so we could get a tease
for what's coming down the line
can comes from croninopolis which was
possibly spotted in a bubble in the
quantum realm
during ant-man in the wasp potentially
this is where the tva is located
and though it is typically placed in the
null time zone i think it would be a
very cool reveal that brings everything
together
now if kang is behind it all then it is
possible that he traveled through every
timeline and that he found the one in
which he could rule for eternity
we saw something similar in infinity war
when we learned there were over 14
million different scenarios for the
thanos battle
but only one in which the avengers won
potentially kang could be in the one
where he is the ruler of all time
and in order to stop anyone from taking
his throne he's been pruning branches
throughout the multiverse
kang may have taken those who created
nexus events and wiped their memories
before putting them into his ranks
so that he could continue his quest to
exterminate everything in the multiverse
all that would be left was a dimension
in which he was unchallenged
and potentially the nexus event that
sylvie would have created
may have been her overthrowing him
obviously that's a completely wild
theory
but let me know below if you disagree
now there is another person that i think
could be behind it all
and they've already been in the show
what if yeah just
sit down for a second what if this
entire thing is actually
miss minutes now we know that there's an
elevator button that leads directly to
her
and it is possible that she's the big
bad the timekeepers are robots
clocks are of course mechanical and the
city that the tva
is based at also looks like the inner
workings of a clock
she's popped up in the series so it
wouldn't come completely out of the blue
and when she was talking to loki it
seemed like she was
recording but also live at the same time
so lots of weird things going on with
the character
and with tara strong voicing her i think
it would be a cool little twist to have
it revealed that she's the one behind it
all
now it could also be a version of loki
doing it and potentially the show may be
pulling from the graphic novel
agent of asgore in that it was revealed
there was an older version of the
character pulling the strings
and we did theorize that richard e grant
would be playing this
though he got the casting right and he
is going to be an old version of loki
judging from the post-credits scene it
seems like we were way off in terms of
his role
however it is worth going over him and
in the graphic novel
we learned that it was old loki all
along
he was the one manipulating the younger
version to excel to greatness
and considering loki has been nothing
but a stepping stone in the mcu
i think that it would be a great reveal
now at the end of the episode we meet
several versions of loki and it does
seem like next episode the main variant
will be recruiting more of these in
order to go and take down the tba
this would explain why vote lucky pops
up in the show and also
why in the trailers there's a brief
glimpse at king loki however beyond that
there may be one hiding under our noses
and it is possible that ravana ren
slayer herself is a loki
the series has confirmed that race and
gender don't matter when it comes to who
is a loki
and you might be a loki you might be a
loki
you might be a loki so so bad now
because of this yeah ren slayer could
even be one herself
and this would explain why she felt some
sympathy towards selfie when she was a
child
somewhat how mobius is in the loop
constantly working with loki
ren slayer may two be stuck in one
constantly hunting them
hell the tva on above bringing loki's in
to hunt other loki's
and this entire show started off on the
idea that tom hiddleston's version would
be tracking down sylvie
thus it does make sense that she herself
could be one
and because the tva are able to wipe
memories this would be
completely unbeknownst to her now
there's no precedent for this in the
comics but i have no idea why she was so
sympathetic towards sylvie
and why she allowed her to escape in the
elevator she also smirked when sylvie
asked what nexus event she created
and though she pretended not to know she
clearly did
and i also know it was you who fought it
in the elevator yeah
get that smile off your face now maybe
this entire show is her simply
attempting to be the superior loki
and the nexus event that sylvie created
was just her existing
i do feel that we're gonna get a twist
that someone who we think is one
character is actually a loki themselves
and if this had to be anyone my money
would be on rentslayer
however she also may simply be the same
as her comic book counterpart
and working for kang in the comics the
two had a relationship
and it would make a lot of sense if she
is indeed tied in with him
now lastly i want to talk about what's
happened to mobius
in the episode he was apparently killed
but loki showed at the end that the
sticks of death could be survived
as he arrived in a decimated new york
potentially the same thing happened with
mobius
and he may even have been taken to
somewhere else in the timeline
trailers for the show have had him
driving along in a jeep in what looks
like
egypt and thus we do know that he's
probably coming back at some point
unless this is all a trick which you
won't fool me mephisto
i know it's you now on top of this
i think that there may be other versions
of mobius that are running around
in ren slayer's office he noticed there
were several ring stains
which she said had been left by him and
even though he brushed it off
he clearly thought it wasn't me now he
also
so really bad this video now he also
looked at pen which he said had been
given to her by another agent
in episode four he looked longingly over
this and it is possible that it comes
from his real life
in the comics there were several
versions of mobius and shout out to zen
media on twitter for pointing out that
the figure we see dotted about on
posters
does look a lot like the comic book
version of him so potentially the one we
see in egypt
is another version of the character i
definitely think that mobius is stuck in
his own loop though and i hope at some
point that he breaks it
and gets to ride that jet ski just give
this man a jet ski
give this man a jet ski now the pruning
itself may not actually be wiping people
out
and judging off what's going on in the
post post-credits scene i think the most
likely scenario is that the characters
are being teleported to a garbage
timeline
also known as 2020. the post-credits
scene
very much feels like it's a dumping
ground and it's almost a sort of
scrapyard timeline in which variants
that are no longer needed are sent to
you
this would mean that mobius might be
there too and i'd love it if they just
had
one big happy reunion and he got right
off of his jet ski
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories so make sure you
comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
show on the 30th of july
in which we pick three random comments
so you can win an mcu box set of your
choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your theories
for the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
episode 4 which will be linked on screen
right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom and pointed out all the
cool easter eggs we could find so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more
without the way thank you for singing
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time
take care peace